>> TENG: Hi there, my name is Karen Teng,
and I lead the development effort over at
Adaptive Blue. Adaptive Blue is a New York-based
startup, focused on using semantic technologies
to create a better web browsing experience.
>> What is your extension about?
>> TENG: Get Glue is an innovative social
recommendation network from movies, books,
and music. The Get Glue browser extension
brings filtered friend reviews, personal recommendations,
and contextual content to popular sites around
the web, such as Wikipedia, Amazon, IMDB,
and hundreds more. Get Glue can understand
that you're on a page about a recognized object,
like a movie, book, or album. When that happens,
it calls the Get Glue API, which then determines
which object it is. The Get Glue API also
returns information about that object, like
core information, recent visitors, and similar
things. The output from these calls are then
transformed via XSL to create the HTML of
the Get Glue bar.
>> How does Glue determine what is currently
being viewed by the user?
>> TENG: Each object on Get Glue has its own
identifier that is generated from its primary
key attributes. These key attributes are category
specific. For example, books can be identified
by title and author, and movies by title and
director. When somebody visits a book on a
recognized site, we extract the title and
author from the page, and query a semantic
database to find a match. Querying a centralized
and authoritative source helps us normalize
across different spellings and editions to
ensure that the same book across sites is
recognized. Semantic DBs are also category
specific. For example, we use Amazon for books
and Netflix for movies.
>> Why do Glue's social features belong in
the browser?
>> TENG: The browser acts as a lens as the
user surfs around the web. And this lens is
an ideal layer to introduce contextually correct,
highly relevant information for the user.
Social connections happen to be a specific
type of contextual information that can be
surfaced by the browser. Get Glue is capable
of understanding the context of a page, and
is then able to pull in the right contextual
information from across the web automatically
onto the page. The extension pulls information
that provides the best experience for the
user, regardless of what the website operator
wants to surface on their page. For example,
when a user looks at a movie on Amazon, they
cannot only see filtered friend reviews for
that movie, via the Get Glue extension, but
they can also watch the trailer, or add it
directly to their Netflix queue.
>> What was your experience like developing
a Google Chrome extension?
>> TENG: We found that developing an extension
for Chrome was a different experience than
doing it for Firefox and Internet Explorer.
The main difference is in the philosophy and
the architecture of Chrome add-ons, which
in turn guided us to a different kind of implementation.
Get Glue is a sophisticated add-on, which
includes semantic analysis of information
on the pages, focuses on the content of hundreds
of popular sites, and surfaces friends' recommendations.
Basically, it wasn't exactly trivial, and
the port to Chrome required substantial effort.
Our main focus was on preserving a common
code base between the browsers while fitting
into Chrome's model of background pages and
content scripts. Once we've figured out the
best way to re-factor our code to make the
two sides communicate, the process became
straightforward. Overall, we found the Chrome
platform to be very flexible easy to code
on. The documentation forms were excellent.
>> How did your vision evolve as you were
working on your extension?
>> TENG: Since we already had a working extension
for Firefox and Internet Explorer, our main
focus was on building the Chrome extension
in a way that fit our architecture, and reuse
most of the code. Throughout the process,
we've focused on optimizing our code, ensuring
that the extension worked quickly and did
not degrade the user's main experience, which
is surfing the web.
>> What were some challenges you faced when
writing your extension?
>> TENG: One area that gave us trouble when
porting the extension was that there was an
architectural mismatch. Our code was relying
on synchronous calls which were impossible
within Chrome. So, we mimicked the behavior
of synchronous requests by creating a cache
facade within the content script. This is
done based on the suggestion from the Chrome
team, who was very helpful throughout the
entire process of the port.
>> How did you promote your extension?
>> TENG: It's important for an extension developer
to find additional promotional opportunities
beyond the great value that the extension
gallery provides. Promoting the extension
on the Get Glue website has definitely helped
with adoption. We show a specific "add to
your browser button" for Chrome users that
includes a Chrome logo, and we've heard that
the familiarity helps them convert. The Get
Glue service rewards users for specific achievements
by awarding them with stickers. Individuals
are prompted to add the extension in order
to earn a unique sticker called "add-on adhesive".
>> What advice can you give someone before
starting to work on a Google Chrome extension?
>> TENG: The advice is to think about whether
they're building a cross-browser solution,
or just for Chrome. If the extension is for
Chrome only, then it should be designed to
take maximum advantage of Chrome's infrastructure,
and native UI. If the goal is to build a cross-browser
solution, then a lot more time needs to be
spent in the architectural phase and making
sure that mismatches between the platforms
are understood and accounted for.
>> What are the next steps for your extension
and your involvement with the platform?
>> TENG: We're solely focused on a single
Get Glue extension. We follow an aggressive
release schedule and are routinely shipping
updates for the extension. It's great that
Chrome makes the upgrade process so seamless
for us, so that we can be confident that everybody
is on the most recent version. We've upgraded
twice already and both times, it's been seamless
and awesome.
>> Come meet the Adaptive Blue team at the
Google IO conference.